[Music]
thank you to everyone for joining
especially to the people who disagree
with me much as i love flame wars on
twitter it is usually not possible to
resolve complex moral issues
in 288 characters so i figured it would
be better to put the memes and the
insults and the one-liners aside and
face the people in the replies
the other day i said inventing a
constitutional right to abortion is the
single worst thing america has ever done
someone angrily replied asking if i
didn't think that perhaps slavery was
worse i said that abortion is much worse
than slavery slavery deprives people of
liberty abortion robs them of life our
nation is predicated on the idea that
our creator endows us with certain
natural rights including life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness but these
rights are not equal rather they depend
upon one another we cannot pursue
happiness unless we have liberty we
cannot have liberty unless we have life
if life and liberty come into conflict
it is incoherent to choose liberty or
a pale perversion of liberty as we see
in the case of abortion
over life since liberty cannot exist
without life so it seems pretty clear to
me that abortion is much worse than
slavery which i tweeted and then all
hell broke loose
so thousands of responses later
memes
insults even death threats i figured i
would invite anyone who is interested on
to show me the lie so thanks for coming
on
what did i say
that was wrong
hey michael
hello how you doing
doing good doing good how do you see
both of them how can you make a
comparison to both one would be
a child in the womb that we should
protect but the other one is the
inferiority of another human being so
i'm i'm not suggesting that slavery is
good
or that you know we can only pick one of
these things to protect babies in the
womb or to not enslave people but
i am making the claim that abortion is
the worst thing that we've ever done
and and we can compare things even
things that are a little bit different
i can compare different kinds of laws i
can compare different kinds of crimes
and that's what we're doing here when it
comes to abortion and when it comes to
slavery so
i can compare a vandalism
and rape both bad things but rape is
worse than vandalism and rape is treated
more seriously by the law than vandalism
is and
rape should be more seriously policed
and discouraged than vandalism or even
some lesser crime than that and in the
case of abortion abortion is much worse
than slavery
so are you using a moral side to this
are you saying that uh the
the intrinsic value of this unborn of
baby
is um
should be more protected or is is worse
than slavery because that's enslaved
person
can get out of it
i think that human beings have the same
intrinsic value i'm not saying that the
unborn baby is more valuable than
someone who is enslaved but i'm saying
the crimes are different so i think
forced labor which is what slavery is is
very different from murdering somebody
and i think that any of us here today if
we were told you can either work for
someone against your will for some
unknown period of time or you can be
killed right now i think all of us
would take
the the former option i think we would
all try to preserve our lives because
death is worse than servitude thank you
very much thank you
hi mike
how are you i'm better now that i'm
talking to you riley
is the argument that abortion is more of
a moral stain on the individual or
society i'm saying both i think it is
immoral at the level of the individual
but also immoral at the level of a
society and my specific claim that led
to this whole hullabaloo is that
abortion is the worst thing that america
has ever done so i was speaking
specifically about the country and the
supreme court in roe versus wade but of
course that which is wrong at the
national level is wrong at the
individual level too one moral quandary
i sort of wrestle with would be
would it be better for an individual to
engage in abortion
and say have a measure of repentance
later on
rather than a person engage in the act
of slavery and have no moral
repentance
that i think breaks the comparison
because then you're comparing things uh
with an extra variable in here that
can't that therefore can't really be
compared uh it would not be better for
the baby for someone to have an abortion
and then repent of it
than to enslave somebody and not repent
of it i guess it might be better for the
person who would potentially have been
enslaved but and it certainly would be
better for the person who repented
because then they can seek salvation but
you see how introducing that that
variable into it makes these things
really impossible i think to compare so
if we're just comparing the two crimes
specifically of abortion and
enslaving somebody there i think we
would agree that there is there's uh no
question abortion is much worse than
slavery
thank you
we're going to bunk next bunk i want you
to deep dim
today buddy i'm doing well
yeah so why why i value the principle of
life as you were defining it well you
you clearly do i guess is what i would
say you want i would ascend value of
life at the point of a conscious
experience a sentient experience to be
more specific so should we be able to
kill people in a coma
should we be able to kill people in a
comatose state no because they would
have stated the um given they're given
preferences before the commodore state
and then we ought preserve those from
when they wake up from the comatose that
seems like an unworkable system what if
we don't know that they're going to wake
up from their comatose state
well it's kind of hard to say that we
just don't know like obviously it's very
easy there are plenty of people where we
don't know if they're going to recover
from their commas that happens often i'm
sure there are people who we don't know
we're going to recover from their comas
i think that we ought to air on the side
of life in that situation
but that's because there was previously
stated preference right so their
preference is all that matters so if
before they go into the coma they say
you know
let's say they had a bad day at work and
they come on they say gosh i don't know
if i want to be on this world anymore
and then they go into their coma then
you think we should honor honor their
preference and kill them actually we
have things within the united states of
america to allow people to die it's
called dnr do not resuscitate order and
that states that they don't want to be
brought back to life and i think we all
respect that preference yes so you so
what what you're saying is rather than
merely debating the issue of of abortion
being
bad at all or certainly being worse than
slavery you're you're advocating for the
goodness of assisted suicide
um i think that these two things
definitely do play uh into each other
right so the idea that we ought to
preserve um something that has yet to
come into existence right the conscious
experience of the conscious preferences
of a baby but but i'm not i'm not
suggesting i want to i want to correct
your premise
i just want to correct your premise
before you get 240 on the right then
we'll get right back to what i was
saying sure so what what you're saying
is if you want to preserve consciousness
but i'm not saying that i am concerned
primarily with preserving consciousness
i'm saying i'm interested with
preserving life and not ending a life
whether the life is conscious whether
the life is uh an adult or uh who has
expressed preferences or a teenager who
expresses preferences perhaps with less
credibility or a child who has not
reached the age of reason and cannot
actually consent to do anything at all
or a toddler or a baby in the womb so
i'm suggesting something more
fundamental than consciousness so what
i'm trying to get at then is that we
don't seem to value um things that will
never have consciousness ever again uh
in the same way that we do value things
that will have a conscious experience or
have assertive conscious preferences
that will have them again would you
agree with that statement i agree that
we yeah we tend to uh regard conscious
beings more than we regard
uh unconscious beings i think frankly i
think that's a little bit part of the
problem
do you think that we should value things
that have not do not have consciousness
that we'll never have conscious again do
you think we should value them the same
that we do a human being i'd i'd have to
know what you do you mean someone who is
brain dead well i think we should value
that we should value them but i think i
think we should value them but it's
perfectly fine to remove their
extraordinary medical care because
they're they're not alive by any real
definition of life but that of course
does not describe it
doesn't describe babies that sounds
really wrong that sounds really morally
wrong no they're already dead is what
you're saying if you're talking about
brain death you're talking about someone
who's already dead so i think we kind of
circled back on this but but i guess
before before i let you go i just i
guess is there any way that this relates
to an unborn baby or to the question of
slavery
the question that we're having right now
is do you value the potentiality of
conscious experience would you value
that i value i value the potential of
all life including conscious experiences
this is a much more interesting branch
of conversation because i can't because
i can integrate straight to the
hypothetical right
i think these conversations are very
interesting i love doing them right
they're my favorite thing in the world
actually um i love discussing ideas it
seems like you do too which is actually
really great um
but the point that i'm getting at is
that if you think we could do you think
we can assign uh moral value to
something that is potential that's not
existed yet
okay we gotta go we gotta move on uh i'm
sorry that we didn't touch on the topic
at hand but i i enjoyed our interaction
yeah i enjoyed interacting too dude have
a nice day lina
hi michael nice to meet you nice to meet
you
um actually i'm not sure exactly where i
stand on this just because i'm not from
the us i'm from canada and in canada
basically there's like no limit on
abortion you can perform an abortion at
any moment during gestation which i
don't agree with but i was just
wondering since we had like a similar
debate in law school um and basically
the teacher explained that
um being pro-life would be just as bad
as slavery since they subjugate women in
the same way that for example black
people are indigenous people are
subjugated
under
white men or white people in general and
then the whole pro-abortion argument was
um like the basis of it was that
the fetus is a part of the woman's body
and because of that like nothing else
matters sure well it's helpful to know
that the word fetus means offspring it's
a latin word and it means offspring and
so when people try to create a
distinction between a fetus and the baby
they're they're talking about a
distinction without a difference
um you you mentioned that your teacher
said that the the fetus the baby is part
of the mother that is manifestly not
true uh the fetus has different uh genes
than the mother so the baby
is
while the baby is within the mother's
body the baby is not just part of the
mother in the way that like my my
fingernail would be part of me or the
cells of my fingernail would be part of
me the baby is unique at the genetic
level at the spiritual level and just
physically you can see it you can look
at it on a sonogram now to the question
of the woman being oppressed by having
to to take care of this baby and how
this is similar to a black slave in
louisiana in the 19th century i think
there's a big difference here i think
the obligations the natural obligations
that a mother has for her own child are
different than
the obligations of of a black slave to
pick enough cotton for his white master
i don't i don't think those are the same
thing i think what the teacher meant
when they were talking about the whole
slave slavery argument was that
basically by not having the
like
the decision to choose whether you have
the kid or not it's the same thing as
taking off
like taking out the rights of black
people so just as
a practical matter the mother does have
the choice in greater than 99 of cases
so these issues of rape or incest in in
abortion account for less than one
percent of all abortions uh so generally
speaking this is consensual sex and when
you have sex with somebody you are
consenting to the consequences of sex
whether you want to admit it or not you
are you are consenting to that act which
which is be getting the child uh then uh
beyond that uh you you get to this issue
of uh even the the one percent or fewer
than one percent of cases that are not
consensual and it raises the question do
you have moral obligations that you
don't consent to and of course we do if
some homeless filthy dirty rotten beggar
showed up on my door dying of thirst i
would have an obligation even though i
don't know this beggar from adam i would
have an obligation to give that beggar
water and to care for that beggar and
then maybe care for the beggar for a
little period of time and then if i were
unwilling to have him become my new
roommate then i would uh get him some
help and someone else could could help
to care for him so i think that's a
pretty good analogy when it comes to to
the baby we we all know that we have
natural obligations to our parents to
our grandparents to our communities to
our country and to to our god and so if
you yes if you look at the issue only
through the lens of rights and what
you're entitled to and your own desires
then you might come to these crazy
conclusions but but our life is not
defined
entirely or even primarily by our rights
it's it's defined i think more more
importantly by our obligations thank you
so much michael yep great great
questions
thaddeus what a great name thaddeus uh
hi michael um i would want to bring you
uh this scenario in which
uh you would the left would try to um
rationalize abortion so say you have a
society
with
um
enslavement
would you want to have that abortion
where a child
would be and that's the relationship
would grow up in there be a slave their
entire life
would it be worth killing that kid
without having like due to all the
misery and trauma that he's going to
suffer throughout his entire life and
i'd like to the answer to be um
try to have like a non-catholic answer
to him because being catholic it's easy
to debunk that but i'm just running if
you could do it from like a purely like
rational standpoint on that let's bring
up that filthy dirty rotten beggar that
i mentioned in an earlier answer there's
a filthy dirty rotten beggar he's got
all sorts of pock marks from all the
drugs that he's used he's covered in
human excrement people walk past him
with contempt and disdain even though
this dirty filthy rotten beggar is
probably never going to improve his
circumstances he's been living like this
for 40 years and he's going to live like
it for the rest of his life
even still i don't think it's justified
to shiv this guy in the middle of the
night and a less extreme version of this
of course would be to ask just about
anybody all of us suffer perhaps slaves
suffer more or suffered more than we do
but that's not true for everybody in the
world you know everybody suffers that's
a fact of life
you have to ask them if it is better
to
to be killed
than it is to suffer is it better not to
be living
or to live but suffer
and even the people who answer that it's
better not to be living are full of it
because they're not killing themselves
because they're here asking the question
and i don't i'm not daring anybody to do
it i don't think it would be good if
they killed themselves but their own
behavior is is showing that they're
being a little dishonest with themselves
it's it's a kind of cognitive dissonance
between their behavior and the thoughts
that they're expressing and i think they
ought to resolve that cognitive
dissonance by observing that their
thoughts have gone a little bit awry and
there's some wisdom in their behavior
and their natural instinct for
self-preservation all right that's it
thank you everybody thank you so much
for coming on i i really appreciate
everyone coming on and you know the
other thing that's really funny is i
guess some people disagreed with me but
the vast majority
agreed with the statement and yet
the statement went viral for being so
outrageous and defensive and i got all
these mean tweets and all these death
threats and all this kind of stuff and
then none of those people
had the guts to come on and actually
discuss the issue because it's very easy
to get hot and angry and sell people and
yell and scream and cry but if you want
to make a coherent argument
that's a little bit more difficult and
it would seem that basically none of the
people who who did that and who made
that tweet go viral were willing to do
that were really probably able to do
that so i think it stands perfectly
clear abortion is much
much worse than slavery thank you for
tuning in
[Music]